let's bring devin booker into the
conversation here book thank you very
much for taking a few minutes with us
this is ernie johnson
hey uh so what have you learned in this
first taste of the postseason what have
you learned about what it takes to win
games in the playoffs i'd say just
keeping your composure
um the game is going to be physical
game's going to be high in high
intensity
you know but just stay with it the whole
48 minutes um
that's what our team's made of that's
what we've been sticking with all season
and
you know i think it wears a lot of teams
down when we play like that
book we're going to the western
conference finals i'll see you not
smiling
it's okay to smile tell us how you
really feel brother hey man i feel good
and i feel really good now i've been
waiting on this for a really long time
um just play off basketball in general
you know a lot of people been saying
you know i haven't played any meaningful
basketball and you know i'm not ready
for that and
you know this is my time to prove it so
you know we're having fun with the whole
teams having fun with it having great
leaders like cp
jay crowd or coach monte around here
helps out a lot
so we're having fun with it well book
number one congratulations you've had a
fabulous playoff run you stepped up
in a big big game answer a question for
me
me and ken we got a little argument when
broke away on that layup late in the
game
do you can he still dunk that's why i
got on him i don't know if he can dunk
off one leg he could for sure dunk
though
he can for sure don't but i went to him
right after that play i told you you got
to get on the rim bro
you got to get on that one time for us
well number one also uh i'm looking
forward to that coconut water brother
oh you already use the number one that
would be number two coco five coming
soon there we go there you go
yes sir yeah i have a question you know
what you
you you ha how you you guys went eight
no in the bubble laughs
how much did that bring into the
momentum
of what you're doing today and if you
didn't go 8-0 do you think it would have
been a different scenario possibly
i think we built the culture down there
honestly um coach monti when they gave
us a chance to to get into the bubble i
think we were one of the last teams in
record wise
you know we just wanted to take
advantage of the opportunity so you know
our gym was good
my workouts are really competitive and
we just went out there with nothing to
lose for real
but we developed a culture we developed
a brotherhood amongst us team and then
going into the off season the addition
of chris jay
and a lot of other guys you know i think
fell right into what we're doing now
and uh book can you just put into
perspective for us
what chris paul has meant to your game
it's hard to put that in perspective man
it's something i'm have to
look back on but you know i always say
when people ask me about chris it's more
you know how he handles himself off the
court you know seeing his routine
seeing how he goes about his business
seeing how he takes care of his body so
you know he's been in this thing for a
really long time he's done a lot of
things that
you know all of us want to reach um you
know so to have him in the backcourt
with me have him on the day-to-day basis
on the planes picking his brain
and just being a sponge to him honestly
you know has helped my game tremendously
34 points 11 rebounds for us is devin
booker congratulations good luck in the
western conference
finals yes sir we appreciate the time
man thanks for congratulations book
congratulations
aj tell aj what's up i got you